Ten signs a psychopath is targeting you
Psychopaths are very dangerous individuals
But perhaps the most dangerous thing about them is the fact that they are hard to spot until it's too late
Too many individuals have been drawn in and charmed by a psychopath only to realize that a monster was lurking behind their seemingly
charming facade
So, how do you tell if a psychopath is targeting you?
Thankfully psychopathy has been an area of high interest for many psychological
Researchers and they've discovered many traits of psychopaths that will give them away at least if you know what to look for
number one grooming
Grooming is when Psychopaths target and prepare their victims
Grooming can include a variety of different activities and tactics like giving gifts help or favors
But the aim is always the same win their trust and encourage submission in order to facilitate mental physical or sexual abuse
Number two Psychopaths will watch you carefully
Psychopaths view people very differently than you or I would look at someone
they see them as little more than prey and the way that they watch their prey is not that different from the hunting tactics of
a lion
Many reveal that when talking to a psychopath. It seems like they're not blinking or showing any emotion
That's because they're scanning you for any weakness
Number three appear as a savior
Sometimes Psychopaths watch you carefully to attack in a non-physical way
They will often come to you as a Savior pretending to have something you want or need
They will give them what they need earn their trust and then threaten to take it away in order to manipulate them
Number four
psychopaths use aliases
Interestingly enough. There are possible overlaps between psychopathy and antisocial personality disorder
people with antisocial personality
disorders tend to use an alias when targeting people as do Psychopaths
number five
Psychopaths can be charming
When a psychopath approaches a victim he or she will often seem incredibly charming but the more sensitive and wary
Individuals will note that there is something wrong or off about this charm. It just doesn't seem right
That's because it's all an act and the psychopath doesn't actually care about you
number six
Psychopaths will try to use you
The end goal of a psychopath is to get something from you many times
This is simply to watch you die or to rape and sexually humiliate you
Other times it can involve manipulating you into achieving their goals
Number seven, you might never see a psychopath coming
The most disturbing thing about Psychopaths might well be their ability to blend in
This makes them difficult. If not impossible to detect you might not be able to tell if someone is a psychopath
Remember they can appear anywhere even in positions of power and responsibility
positions that are supposed to be occupied by people that you can trust
number eight
Psychopaths will talk in a certain way
Psychopaths have trouble controlling their desires and this can manifest itself in a very visible way
Psychopaths often seem very impulsive and are unable to focus on one thing for a long time
Especially if they are attracted to numerous things at once this can become obvious in the way a psychopath stalks and communicates
number-9 learned helplessness
Learned helplessness is an interesting phenomenon. It's defined as a condition in which a person suffers from a sense of powerlessness
Arising from a traumatic event or persistent failure to succeed. It is thought to be one of the underlying causes of depression
This is a commonly used tactic by psychopaths to
Psychologically break people if you can instigate learned helplessness in someone it will destroy their self esteem and deeply humiliate them
number 10
Psychopaths will isolate you
Another thing that Psychopaths will often try to do is get you alone
This is because Psychopaths can better manipulate you or harm you when you're in a one-on-one setting they know that individuals
Especially shy ones will be more submissive and more likely to obey when they don't have the safety of others to turn to in
Addition Psychopaths know that they are more likely to get away with their crimes if no one is watching
Do you know anyone with five or more of these signs?
Share your thoughts below
If you like this video be sure to LIKE and subscribe to see more content like this from safe to go. Thank you for watching